hello everyone and welcome to cloud on
air live webinars from
were loud we are host
every Tuesday I'm Ricardo I'm the lead
for G suite front and security and I'm
Alberto I'm a manager within the counter
abuse team today we're going to deep to
dive deep into Gmail and we're going to
talk about how we protect users against
malware and some where spam and phishing
while we do the presentation you can
leave questions in the platform and at
the end of presentation we're going to
answer a few of them live if we don't
get to your question don't worry we will
answer them later and in the platform so
here's what's going to happen in the
next 30 minutes so first we're going to
talk about the the major threat vectors
that are in scope for this presentation
we're going to present several
techniques to address these threats and
in particular we're going to see how a I
can help detection and finally we are
going to put it all together and see how
all these techniques are used
effectively to protect users and then as
I said before we're going to have a
short Q&A where we answer your questions
so here's here's the threat vectors we
can see that for for this presentation
the first one is spam right spam is just
unsolicited unsolicited promotional
messages we've all got a lot of them
they are ubiquitous they are not a
threat per se but if if they are not
kept in check if the number is not kept
in check then it becomes a significant
drain on the users time and resources
and so on I think recent estimates put
the damage due to spam in in only
American enterprises at about 20
billions per year then there's fishing
of course the phishing messages
impersonate legitimate email
communications and they trick the user
into giving out their credential to the
attacker to the Fisher so most of them
the one the one that you might have also
gotten in your Inbox
they are large-scale campaigns so you
will get an even says that says please
click here to reset your PayPal password
these are sent to millions of users but
it's also important to talk about spear
phishing especially in the you know
context of the enterprise these are
targeted attacks that use information
about the user about the victim to be
more effective and also they
a lot of Defense's based on trends and
and large and you know large large
numbers because they affect a single
user then there is a malware right so
malware is just a malicious payload that
is delivered by a virus means they run
with food privileges on the on the
user's machine so they can do pretty
much whatever they want lately in the
news we've seen ransomware it's been
very popular so this this variant of
malware will encrypt your data and then
ask for a ransom to the captured it and
give it back to you but more traditional
email has been used to get a food to
link into organizations that's very
common so the so called advanced
persistent threat of putting model in
one generate user into the organization
is a good way of then expanding your
accident organization and staying
undetected and then there are where
there are client attacks so these are
exploit vulnerabilities in in clients
and web applications and the execute
code on the victims device and depending
on the type of vulnerability they could
it could be you know it could lead to up
to the same kind of infection and you
get from malware now Alberto is going to
describe some techniques that we employ
to mitigate these threats alright so
yeah we've enumerated a few of these
attack vectors and well we'll take a
quick tour of techniques that we see
these abuse actors to deploy these
attacks and consequently we'll talk
about what we do to detect them predict
them and make sure that we minimize the
effect that they have on our users so
we'll give you a glimpse of what our
team does why it's it's a hard problem
and also maybe it will give you some
insights into what to do to prevent
there's a human factor always present
and one uses to be aware and never let
their guard off so we'll we'll go
through some of these techniques some of
these attack vectors like I said this is
too many of them to cover in this talk
but we'll mention some of these and
hopefully it will give you an idea of
what we see and
we do right so first thing I want to do
imagine that there were no spam filters
right I can and there's something that's
someone that's sending you an email
did you like right so you do like it the
first time don't think much of it but
then you keep a counter right like you
receive it for a second time maybe a
third time you notice that these are all
sent by someone let's call them Bob
right well what you might do if you have
the ability to write some rule right
would be to like say if the email is
coming from Bob then let's mark it as
read delete it put them in and put them
in some other folder well that's more or
less what we do when people mark unisys
pam or we find out through other means
then an email is is back
we extract several features from their
email and we keep a count on how often
we see bad emails versus good emails
showing those you see here the screen
some examples of some of those features
the obvious ones are the AP address the
email address of the sender and then
more aggregated features like well Class
C networks or domains till these starts
like the length of the message words
that are mentioned callers aspect ratios
you name it right and what we do is we
keep a counter keeping a tally of how
often we see values of those features
associated with badness now if you want
to take it a step further you can
combine this say I'm ap address is sort
of bad you've seen a few of them maybe
20% of our like it's it's hard to take
and just put them all on this one folder
right so what we do is combine them
right maybe you see partly shady IP
address but the domain is really bad
right maybe those two combined can be
enough evidence so that you can send an
email actually to to the spam folder now
I'm even more powerful technique is if
you can combine those features before
you do the aggregation so now you're
tracking how to specific values all the
featur together are related to badness
so now we see what value specifically
coming from one ISP
and continuing specific words how often
those two together are related to bad
news now if you're doing the math like
imagine you have like a thousand of
these features pairwise combinations are
tuples of more more than those you could
clearly explore if you multiply that by
all the possible values it's no way we
could keep track of that so I guess part
of the secret sauce that we have is
figuring out which and this to track
over time how to evolve them and make
sure that we keep the set that gives us
the most mature right now if if if
you're the person sending you the same
else is persistent they would probably
be aware that you block them and they
will try to change and go around your
filter right nowadays it's easy enough
to just get a new IP address between you
certainly getting a new email address so
we want to do is just pick you know a
bit harder for the abuses to go around
that protection so reputation is great
but we need to figure out what aspects
are hard for the abuses to go around and
which ones they can just circumvent
easily so that that prompts the question
of like what is it that for example
let's focus on fishing what is inherent
to fishing and it has to deceive some
right it has to prompt them into
clicking on this link give it
discussing their password information
executing a file and so on so one way to
give legitimacy to that is to pretend to
be someone else right an authority some
with a lot of money a business partner
of your organization depending on how
much they know about you right and we
see like you example you see in the
screen someone might be presenting to be
a Google tech support now if you just
straight out say Google tech support
right it's easy for us to catch that so
we'll try to do some of this called
spoofing which means you write some
sentence um word that can be interpreted
as something but literally doesn't say
that so you can
replace cereals for elves you can use
what's called Unicode home oak leaves
which are characters that look exactly
the same that maybe characters and
you're used to saying but they're not
the same character so any naive matching
algorithm would miss them so of course
we need to be aware of those and check
for similarity we used canonicalization
of strings to bring them back to a form
that can be compared and there's a whole
spectrum of sophistication right like so
in the end of more sophisticated attacks
you can see even attacks where they
target a specific say brand of
smartphone where that font makes like
two V's together look like a W but not
in others and then that makes even
though that narrows down the the
spectrum of victims they can fall for
this it also makes our orange Oh a
little bit harder because now you have
to pretend or try to render these things
in different platforms so you can see
how this thing is it's not that easy to
to scale what they will also do of
course it's do this poofing not only in
the display name they will use sometimes
they will put an email address in the
display name because you cannot easily
spoof their email address but if you put
on your display name pretending that
that is your email address you could do
it of course we try to detect that you
could also put strings prompting you to
click in there so to inherit this sum of
money that we can also detect so the try
to spoof that now as things get more
sophisticated they move from like
character level spoofing to two images
which brings us to the next topic right
like one way to also again give
legitimacy to do this to this deceitful
message is to provide the same visual
similarity or visual theme of a
legitimate email right now you might
just toss a logo in there again pixel by
pixel is pretty easy for us to catch but
of course it's also easy for them to
circumvent you just randomly in some
pixels maybe like core
our distances that are hard for that for
the eye to catch and then that force us
did make some more fuzzy matching then
you can change the phones you can you
can you can do stuff to trick the
filters so we've been moving over to to
machine intelligence so when we talk
about AI we mentioned this to check
whether a logo it is sufficiently
similar to one that you were we are
trying to protect and even the the
layout the fonts the placement of the
buttons the the overall colors now just
the fact that something look an email
looks like like a legitimate one from
from another brand doesn't mean the
email is bad of course so again with the
future reputation case we combine these
things with with others so that we
accumulate enough evidence to decide
whether immuno emails good or bad
now about visual similarity we have to
say this
we even see cases where there is no
additional visual indication or advance
logos just with the text they're still
able to trick some users so nothing
replaces if you're a domain
administrator administrator nothing
replaces a good policy of keeping users
aware and constantly reminding them to
keep their card the last technique we're
gonna gonna cover is about malicious
attachments right again just like any
antivirus check we do check some files
because files can be used as Ricardo
mention to create a botnet and have your
your computer join someone else to
launch attacks against either other even
other organizations they can installs
over to what were you're doing either to
get your credentials or or just for
espionage and they could use around
somewhere so there's a whole spectrum of
bad stuff that can happen once they get
a foothold into into an organization's
computer right even if it's someone not
not that consequential in the
organization for like financial purposes
they can use that to get to the person
who controls the accounts to the CEO or
get information
social engineer and so on so we
definitely want to do all we can to
prevent these things from ever being
able to be executed so Gmail already
disallow some types of attachments are
being present but as farmers to have
other ways to do this they can take
advantage of traditionally
non-executable formats like documents we
use PDF here's an example but there are
others where you can embed any binary
object right there's also more shady
ways of embedding like executed macros
requiring the user to interact with the
document in some way to launch these
macros they will even download the
content dynamically so they can keep
updating this and and changing it so
that the virus signature so much so
together with advanced techniques for
extracting this these embeddings we need
to apply techniques for likes unboxing
where we can execute these things in a
restricted environment we can monitor
whether they're trying to go home for a
command-and-control Center or trying to
access your files to encrypt them in the
case of ransomware and so on so Google
has a range of signatures that we match
against for a regular AV but but we do
all sorts of prediction and these
sandbox and techniques to also apply to
new cases that we've never seen we have
to say also G's which offers
configuration options if you are a
domain administrator we recommend you to
keep keeping in touch with configuration
options familiar familiarize yourself
with them and determine with their level
of comfort it is according to the tier
of the product that you have and the
risk aversion vs. how much you want to
delay messages because you want to scan
them or get them immediately deliver to
to the inbox now given the sheer scale
of email and frankly the sheer scale of
spam which both range in the billions
per day and the time that this platform
or this medium of communication has been
around you see dos equis as you could
probably imagine there's a huge amount
of knowledge
accumulated over the years for
classification of spam that would be
very hard for us to maintain as a list
of just rules right like getting rid of
the old ones not useful anymore merging
ones that have like almost the same it
would be pretty daunting task so AI is a
foundation that lets us do several
things one of them is its service of as
a repository of knowledge that is
constantly being updated and things that
are not relevant anymore get get taken
out as part of a training process
artificial intelligence and machine
learning models in particular also adapt
over time new things as long as you see
them in the field the sisters will learn
to recognize it and lastly depending on
the technique you use they also have the
capability the capability to predict so
you show them examples you've never seen
before there's a possibility you'll
still catch them we want to exploit that
and that's why we we keep continually
trying new methods that will allow us to
be more proactive
so in general AI enables Google to wall
protect users and against the views we
also do recommendations all other cool
stuff with what machine intelligence but
in the case of Gmail we were one of the
early adopters within the organization
to to harness the power of AI but over
the years we built like a pretty good
mix of traditional proven techniques and
more like sort of cutting-edge newer
technologies we have a pretty
significant linear regression classifier
model because that's what we started
with and I will still keep it but over
the time what we've come up with is a
multi layer multi pipeline set up a
multi layer I mean take a convulsion of
neural network that you use to recognize
visual features is something a logo or
the presence of some-some
particular graphic elements that in
itself usually won't be enough to
classify something as bad so there is if
again one more feature that we can
extract via a machine learning to
determine yes there is a logo there's
not a logo then you combine that with
other features so you can feed that into
either manual rules or more likely to
another model so we have multiple layers
and we have imperil this parallel
pipelines in such a way that even the
final verdict we can get from multiple
master models so we can put them against
each other make sure that we're getting
the both the best of both worlds you can
get like a second opinion of sorts of
view if you will so so the machine
intelligence landscape is one thing you
have to keep continually maintaining now
it would be great if this would maintain
itself it's not so so our team needs to
keep continually adapting the training
of the models monitoring how well it's
detecting what is supposed to be
detecting and and checking against new
attacks
so some challenge challenges that we we
find is all start with the training
right you sample specific instances of
both money source emails and good emails
you need to teach the system to
recognize both with the right set of
features you need to make sure that
they're labeled correctly right you
cannot take every spam mark as face
value you have to do some sort of
cleanup and make sure that those run
reliably and constantly that you are
able to train your models with enough
canons be that every month or a week
every day or maybe continuous learning
models you have to get into that cadence
to make sure that you're constantly
discarding all information incorporating
a new one
keeping your model tight and optimized
another aspect that is particular to
spam is that not everyone agrees what is
spam right like what some person or some
person might be completely undesirable
from some other what might be a mile
annoyance from some other person might
be just like no useful advertising that
they happen to read every once in a
while so it will be
hard for us to keep like a personalized
fully-fledged machine very much for for
every one of our users like after all
this these models do take up space but
luckily you don't have to do that
there's a there's a big section of the
of the email spectrum where you can
pretty much agree that they're good that
they're back we can keep the gray area
as a parameterize option where you can
feed it along with other signals you can
tell your model okay these are the
features coming in from that from the
email but these are also the the
Preferences of the user so you can
adjust your thresholds and make the best
decision for each of our users now
another challenge is models will make
mistakes you need to have a strategy to
deal with those mistakes to treat them
differently depending on the type of
mistake there is and to systematically
diminish them over time it is true that
models like I said before they will
adapt over time and they will predict
new situations but when they fail
typically they don't recover instantly
right it will take time for them to
catch up that means we do have the rules
engine blacklist other like maybe less
sophisticated techniques but you need
those to account for for those gaps now
we talked about errors errors are not
the same right errors are there's
different types of errors and there's
different like problem spaces it takes
time for example if if it meets a
spamming email it's up in your inbox
it's an annoyance you might not think
that much of it and like maybe delete it
hopefully you'll mark it as spam and
help us learn but but maybe that's the
end of it right but uh but on the other
end if we if we take a good email and
put it in the spam folder
am I making me something important for
your for your business
it might make you miss something
important for someone you know and so on
so clearly they're not the same right
for phishing is kind of the opposite but
not quite say if we send something to
the spam
thinking it was fishy you miss it yeah
we already established that is bad but
if we really miss a phishing email put
it in your inbox at your secured ID the
potential like for disaster is it's much
bigger right so there's really no good
or bad error in here there's still
imbalance but both are bad so what we do
in that case is we try to mitigate the
effects of these errors by having what
we could call software hammers like like
in the case you do not completely sure
something it's a phishing email instead
of sending it to the spam folder we can
put some some warnings in place some UI
hints and Ricardo will we'll cover some
of those so that if you're a domain
administrator you can keep your users
aware and always on the lookout for this
for their signals how this all looks
together like I said over the years our
like we have a pretty significant linear
classifier so of the 99.9% of spamming
and harmful email that we detect about
nine-tenths of that is already caught by
this classifier right but of the rest of
the remaining percentage about half of
various heuristics that means this rule
engine that I was mentioning earlier and
and the rest is for with more advanced
machine learning techniques now this is
not the full picture this is not like
disjoint sets right like there's still a
lot of overlap we try to maximize that
overlap actually that's by design this
is a concept called defense-in-depth if
you want to get through our defenses
you should always need to break more
than one thing so that it's not easy for
you that you just like hit the jackpot
and want one thing and then you're in
right so so what we see here is only
additional coverage and we would like to
keep that small so that there's no
single point where you can just like
trick our defenses and getting like
question mark you see there it's of
course next-generation we're always
investing in new techniques there might
be higher low tech than my involved
machine intelligence or not we're
constantly deriving new features pushing
for new standards and then we can use to
protect the identity of the integrity of
females and so on so that's that like a
constantly evolving field so next we'll
go to see how we perform the
classification and what events have a
meaning to our users and how can
identify what happened within the
classification process okay
so Albert has shown all these powerful
techniques you know IV scanning how the
spam classifier works so how does Gmail
put it all together to protect the users
against this threat factors that we
presented before to explain that I think
it's it's easier it's easy to just go to
the flow of a message from the sender to
the user to the end user and we're not
talking just about going from the outbox
of the sender to the inbox of the user
but we'll also consider how the user
interacts with the message once it has
been delivered to the inbox okay so in
particular we are interested in what
happens when the message is malicious of
course because if our our purpose is to
showcase the defenses hopefully nothing
happens if the message is benign and so
we are going to see how a malicious
message flows the that you know that
we're going to see that life cycle of a
malicious message and here is here the
old irrelevant steps in more detail they
are sorted in temporal order so on the
left you see delivery which is the first
step and then on there all the way to
the right you see that you see actions
that are taken by the user on the email
because you know you're soon that going
from left to right you already opened it
and everything right we are going to go
to each one of them in detail
of course because there are many okay so
note that something is not shown in this
flow is that delivery and sync the first
two phases happen on the server so they
will be able to use all the intelligence
that that learner talked about all the
other phases are happen on the client
also know that reclassification is not
quite defined in a single place in the
order that's because by definition it
can happen at any time our
classification is the process of real
of rescanning old messages with updated
rules updated AV signatures and so on
and making changing the the verdict of
the classifier and syncing the
information to the client so this can
happen at any time or not happen at all
right this can can insert itself into an
into any moment okay so here all the
defense's that we provided during the
life cycle this is so Alberta mentioned
before about the spam classifier that
defense in depth
right this is another example of defense
in depth so as you can see to flow from
all the way to the left all the way to
the right you have to go through a lot
of these defenses so there's multiple
layers here to that so if you are
overwhelmed the amount of red crosses
and names on the slide that's perfectly
fine that actually was intended this
slide is meant to be overwhelming
because it gives me an excuse to now go
through all the various spaces and
explain how all these defenses affect
the delivery and and an ongoing attack
right when it comes to malicious email
so the first phase is delivery this
happens when we receive the message in
in our mail servers but we haven't
delivered it to the user yet and in fact
we might not deliver it at all so a lot
of the spam messages or spam phishing
malware whatever that never makes it to
the users inbox or even the spam folder
so we don't just decide whether it
whether we send an email to the inbox or
the spam folder we can also act it all
together if you think you have a lot of
spam email in your spam folder right now
imagine if you had ten times as much
that's more or less I think an
approximate figure about how much we
reject altogether versus what we put in
spam note that most of our detection
capabilities are here as I mentioned
before this is one of the things that
happen on the server so this is where
all of our intelligence are available
the later phases will basically use
metadata that has been generated here
and use it because now that when you're
on the client now you can have user
visible effects miss fight beside
rejecting the most common bit of
metadata that to give an example is of
course the spam bit right is this Pam or
is it or is it not so does it go in the
inbox or is it going
spam folder but there are other pieces
of metadata by that we're going to show
so this is the second phase is sync so
again we're gonna skip a classification
because it asked that doesn't actually
have an order the second phase is sick
so we this is when the server's push the
message to the client so that becomes
available to the user and it sees it in
the thread listed in the list of unread
messages from our security standpoint we
need to do to make two main tasks here
alright so the first one is to propagate
all this security relevant metadata that
I mentioned before so that we became
implement client-side defenses the
second main goal is to sanitize
untrusted content right the main the
main purpose here is to sanitize the
message body which of course the email
protocol doesn't doesn't doesn't define
anything related to like what what kind
of malicious content can appear in the
body how much the HTML can be dynamic
and so on so we do have a very strict
policy about what can be served to do on
the user's device the idea is that the
server does the heavy lifting when it
comes to sanitization right so the
client gets a piece of HTML that is
already safe to display and then we have
message open right so this is the face
that happens when the user you know
assuming the user selects a message
opens it and now can can see its
contents right so this is a good place
for us to give visual cues about
security issues so we can inform the
user about something that is maybe
relevant or warn the user about
something that is definitely suspicious
this is all these cues are about those
gray areas that are too talked about
like if I'm in email is definitely
malicious then you wouldn't get here but
we do there's a long tail of emails that
have some suspicious behavior or
features that we cannot quite put in the
spam folder so this is this would be
where we start warning the user rights
and from now on one example is of course
the right journey showing a warning
banner right so a banner that says look
this this could be fishing this
descender these words were often
associated with fishing so be careful
another example of a visual cue here is
something on up to date virus check so
we reissue a virus check the same thing
that has been done during delivery
we redo it when the message is open and
there isn't what we do it is because
potentially the a/v has been updated
with signatures and the ID could be a
give a different verdict recursively
who's supposed to take care of that so
we do have eventual consistency
eventually across litigation we will do
it with even when the user doesn't open
and push the update but the issue that
reconciliation is a background job that
is that could take minutes to execute
and the I guess we want to close this
window vulnerability as soon as the a B
as a new signature we should be we
should it should have this viewable
effect on the user's inbox so in that
case we would warn the user and prevent
the download after the message is open
that the user is going to interact with
it right and depending on what type of
threat we talk about if is phishing
malware and so on we focus on on
different actions like if your message
has is carrying an exploit then the most
relevant phase is done valve an
attachment so let's go to a scenario
where the user sends a malicious PDF
that is supposed to exploit a adobe
reader vulnerability right so the first
phase is that is that maybe nothing
happens at all right because every show
before during the Newbery we could
reject the message so Gmail might not
know the user might not see that at all
right the inbox is still empty because
the email was never delivered to the
user so let's assume again defense in
that so let's assume that one layer
fails the the message gets through
because the these signatures were not
were up-to-date this is a very novel
threat that our abs couldn't handle so
the user then sees a message and decides
to open it so all is not lost right so
we have a few extra additional layers of
defense for example we have not just a
virus scan but we also have a lot of
heuristics regarding what is risky right
so if this is a if the attachment is
suspicious then we can at least warn the
user we don't have enough confidence to
reject the message because we don't we
haven't matched an exact virus sample
but we have at least we can at least a
user that the attachment is suspicious
and for that we can use the warning
banners as I mentioned before even if
there is no even if the if the the
message if the attachment was not
malicious or at least was not detected
by the virus when a message was
delivered it's possible that is because
it was due to an out-of-date signature
that eventually gets updated because of
course we we continue improves our
signatures and we also purchase updates
from from antivirus vendors so it's
possible that at some point the renter's
would change its mind so as I said
before we do a massive e check that
message open and that would prevent you
from from opening the file as I said the
reason is of course because the
reconciliation can take time in one we
want to reduce this window of
vulnerability but so let's assume that
the exploit is also not known when they
use a user opens the message so even
even the the up-to-date virus check
doesn't detect anything right so the
user is not alerted and falls into the
into the into the trap and opens the
attachment right well the user is still
not going to be compromised the reason
for this is that for a lot of very
common file types like PDF and doc and
so on we have an embedded preview this
is just an HTML preview of the of the of
the content that appears in the browser
window so that of course it's it does
it's not vulnerable to PDF exploits
right so the if to get exploited finally
miss unfortunate can happen is that the
user needs to also download the
attachment so let's go to a different
path now that is usually taken by by
Phish email instead so in a phishing
email that you know you're probably
gonna have a some text that entices the
user into clicking on a link going on a
website and entering their password then
because it because you asked for the
credentials rights this is probably
going to be look looking like a common
service like Google and it will ask for
the passwords so let's go over the
scenario again so first thing is that we
are going to assume that the previous
defenses have already failed not because
they are more likely to fail for
phishing so we're talking about the
jacking at delivery and showing all the
various message banners right
not because they are more likely to but
just because for priority right we have
defense in that we know that we know how
doesn't work so let's move on to the
face that is different for now so let's
assume that the message gets to the user
inbox and the user opens it
and then there is no warning relative to
fishing through banners and therefore it
clicks on the link right like in this
case please click here to the secure
reset your password well there are two
things that can happen that will prevent
the user from actually going to the site
the first is that in those gray areas
where the backing classifier has low
confidence about about about the
reputation of the of the link we can at
least show a warning prompt this will
hopefully discourage the user about
proceeding to the site or at least alert
him that he needs to be extra careful on
this side and the second thing is that
we are going to do an up-to-date
browsing check now the browser also has
a chrome at least has a Safe Browsing
blacklist synced on the client and the
one but but but the one using the
director is more up-to-date and more
comprehensive the point is again being
more up-to-date and then Tentacles
education which also would detect this
but that can take time and even if the
user gets no warning and enters the
password if the user is taking proactive
steps then even then the attacker
account is not compromised right so for
example 2-step verification means that
stealing the password is not enough to
access the account we had a webinar I
think a month ago regarding how to set
it up for your organization and oh sorry
and the other thing that we also
discussed that last month was password
reset extension which also needs to be
set up for the organization for the user
and it's very useful because it will
reset the password immediately if it's
typed on another side another type of
phishing attack is author ID so this is
the ideas that we're going to fish for
what permissions instead of credentials
and it's it's effective because users
are less wary of the link of delegating
access over a granting permission
compared to giving up credentials at
least for enterprises we cannot can
block this attacks by white listing
which applications can ask for
permission to the user and then the
final other that I want to go through is
business email compromise so this is
very important for enterprises and the
idea of this attack is that the feature
entices the user to send confidential
information directly to the attacker bar
playing to the message so not by going
through a site but just by replying to
the email and let's go through a
scenario and see how are the Frances
play play with it so let's assume that
the user gets an email from a CEO of
this that's a he's an employee receives
an email from the CEO and says please
I'm it's urgent please give us the
detail can you send them to us and so
first thing is that the user are not so
easy to fool when they use Gmail because
most of these attacks require the sender
to prevent to pretend to be in the users
organization so one defense that is
super effective against this is out to
the main warning we warn the user that
this person is not in the organization
so obviously the user will immediately
figure out that something fishy is
happening but let's assume again defense
in that that's assume that this fails
so the user gets fooled and the pressure
set that is still not going to be if the
admin is taking proactive steps that is
not could be going to be leaked anyway
we have this feature called data loss
prevention that will run on outgoing
email and scan it for sensitive
information such social security number
and bank accounts so in this case the
user is typing the pad is typing
something and this is an iPhone and a
European banking account identifier and
if we have a property IP rules in place
we can stop this message from actually
going to the feature so to recap we went
through these defenses hopefully now
that you've seen them all one by one
this this slide is less daunting the
main takeaway is again defense in that
so many layers before and a user can can
be can be exploited and can you know can
be attacked and that's it for the talk
so we are going to be moving on to Q&A
now after a very short break I think
around a minute
you
okay so we're back we have a few
questions here and remember that if we
didn't go through your questions we'll
go through them offline on the platform
so first one is what should uses be
aware of regarding new trends in
phishing or malware well there's a
growing trend of going to to actual
malware like us as you get better at
detecting phishing attacks there's this
there's the ongoing trend that we're
seeing of moving on to malware attacks
they're easier to hide it's it's it's
it's hard for us to execute every single
malicious content and attacked every
single second thing that it will do like
imagine something that allows you to
click on some on some elements of the UI
you can only do so much about that so so
it's it's it's a growing threat our like
detection of of content being intolerant
to the user's computer and we need to
execute that in a safe environment for
us to determine whether it's harmful
it's something we're investing heavily
on there's also within the phishing
arena it's moving on to more
spearfishing like they only invest in
knowing a little bit more about the
target and will try to convince them
with specific information viral fish has
been going down but the spearfishing
it's it's less in numbers less
paralleling numbers but they're much
more damaging and much more likely to
succeed like we've repeated during this
talk nothing replaces good awareness
program and because of the reminder of
this for the users who never let their
guard off so so good question what are
specifically the best steps to protect
against spearfishing well some of these
things we covered in the previous talk
we recommend strongly suggest you yeah
you go ahead and watch that but heed the
warnings we try our best not to make any
of our warnings be a sort of cry wolf so
that they become like sort of
unconsciously bypassed by by a user so
here we also need the the collaboration
of domain administrators to make sure
that people heed those warnings data
loss prevention you need to configure it
to work correctly according to the types
of information you want to prevent from
getting out of your of your organization
well look at your like domain directory
if people are spoofing them or at the
name of the CEO keep those updated
there's many things you can you can do
to improve the security of your home
enterprise for this one I think the most
important one even though it takes some
effort is set up 2-step verification if
you really care about not getting
Spearfish definitely by ask you to have
security key there it cost about twenty
dollars you set it up Google supports it
and that is the I think the best way of
preventing fears spear phishing or at
least preventing the attacker from
accessing your account when you your
password gets fished i mean thing if
your enterprise then the best thing to
do is buying all your employees this key
okay so the third question is for mobile
clients that are their protections
available there as well at the oldest
protection available yes most of them
are so sometimes the challenge of course
is how do you show these queues in
reduced UI but most for example the
banners that we saw they are all
available and I think most of all this
all the stuff that is there is based on
on server-side functionality like DLP or
ejecting on delivery console dairy and
putting in the spam folder that's also
all available I think of the ones that
we saw the only true that were not
available where one was antivirus
checking up-to-date because of but of
course on mobile and viruses that
deliver attachments are not as big of a
threat because you cannot just execute
an apk on Android for example and most
malware it ends up being for Windows and
the other one was preview because we use
the embedded previewer of on your mobile
device
for example and under views I think I
forgot what it's called
PDF reader but anyway it's a with of
course on Android the applications are
usually usually written in Java at least
some part are written in Java and they
are more resilient or from from next
points that's all right okay yeah that's
all the questions so please tune in next
Tuesday we're gonna have more webinars
so I have the topics here so we have
data analytics and machine learning IT
infrastructure and collaboration and
productivity so thank you for watching
and see you guys next time
Thanks
you